[Music]
why do you need to do this cuz that's
what I'm gonna that was just with all
the ladies from oceans eight at their
premiere this week so good but if they
do in oceans nine they all said they
would like you to be the one to join
them I mean I'm in ladies they already
had like the story isn't it like the
biggest oceans ever with all of them
combined hello such a fun a me too me
too love it I have to see him again - no
it's real so the show is called love is
so what is love to you oh love is being
able to be at this time in my life and
be able to create beautiful stories
where people can see themselves
particularly black women particularly
black Ben because you know years ago I
remember thinking what's missing with
black love stories african-american love
stories you know we have the sex and we
have the lust and we have the hot and we
have all that but what's missing is
tenderness and so what this show does
better than anything I've seen other
than sugar actually is the intimacy and
the tenderness just the tenderness
I think Mar bracha keel is one of the
best in creating that I was telling her
one time throughout my life she's given
me these characters who yes I can relate
to so now the game see Mary Jane this is
the honest-to-god truth
I always wanted to work with Mara and
Selene but they were over BT and I don't
want to start no nothing no war going on
are you trying to steal so I just I had
just said to myself that's not gonna
happen
so you just have to let that go and you
know what now it's happened when she
told me a while ago she was working on
today and I was like Belize Jesus
I was not III it isn't even the kind of
thing that I dreamed up you know it just
again says to be that anything's
possible because I always wanted to work
with her but I thought oh she belongs to
someone else
I'm never gonna she's never going to
leave that contract
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]